it's very cool to have you here on the
show i know you don't do these kind of
things a lot so thank you for for being
here
first of all thank you sir if you
couldn't hear what he said he just said
i love you conan now uh
sound in the audience
yeah
um
first of all there's so much to talk
about but you're you're
god
got to regain control of this show but
how
how
um
your books are are known for their sort
of their their their dark substance
they're very original but they have a
sort of a dark quality to say the least
when you give readings
people have been known to pass out some
people
even throw up during the readings of
your when you do it and that's not i'm
not even kidding about that that's
that's true is that is that not correct
36 people this year on tour and eight of
those people were in italy in hearing it
in italian which was great is the best
compliment of all time well what are you
telling me you're you're reading from a
story or you're reading from a selection
of your work and it's it's so disturbing
to them that what do they do they they
just keel over oh they pee their pants
sometimes they stand in line to get a
book signed for two or three hours with
their pants wet
i do not want to be standing next to
that person right and then i have to
shake their hand
right
they laugh they pass out two people have
gone to the hospital it's just amazing
now now your your pub
your publisher actually get got upset
with you at one point because i would
think getting that kind of i mean you're
getting such a strong reaction it means
you're doing something right obviously
but your publisher was not happy when at
one of these signings people started to
fall over pass out need oxygen during
the signing they actually uh they got
upset is that right it was a young man
at columbia university the roon arledge
concert hall it was enormous it was like
2 000 students this man falls backwards
falls forwards falls on the floor vomits
starts to aspirate his vomit starts to
bark like a dog while he's passed out at
that point the publishing people come to
the foot of the stage and they say
chuck over here they say do not read
another word of this story go right to q
a you've done enough damage
i have to go back to the podium while
the paramedics are taking this poor
barking choking man out
and i have to say who wants to hear the
rest of the story and it's 2 000 hands
everyone except for the random house
people so i finished the story and it
went fine by the way just me
interviewing you has called because
molly sims to just start
just this interview what is your problem
are you okay
i am so sorry i'm so sorry
i mean he hasn't said anything shocking
at all and you're just no hat took a
drink and he was like by the way i have
mono and i tried
wait a minute black guy
wait and i'm so sorry you have mono no i
know
no but i like guys
i double like drank and i started
chilling can i drink that one yeah and
i'm so sorry
i got mono from her and quentin
tarantino
i'm sorry i didn't i'm sorry i was just
joking you want more
you
know i thought it was so cool to have
you on we're going to find out all these
amazing things
and then look what's happening
if i hadn't killed all that time up
front think of all the time we'd have
now i apologize it's the it's that joke
i did about mccartney
he refers to his 14th is the fab four
now
that's winning them over now um
now what kind of stuff specifically are
you reading that's causing
people to get so upset like what were
you reading in that instance
it's it's a funny story about three ways
that masturbation can go wrong and the
first one is very funny i know
curious about the third but it can kill
you it can kill you it almost killed
somebody i met in a sexual sex addict
support group while i was researching a
book and so these are three true stories
that i heard from sex addicts and so
these are true stories about how
masturbation can cause uh great harm and
they were so disturbing that
they're hilarious stories
they're fantastic stories undoubtedly
um do you have i wanna is that in the
latest book
it'll be in playboy magazine next year
good okay
save my life now uh
fight club is probably your best known
uh
work and that was its delicate cause and
effect but because fight club was so
popular and and and really the the
central idea was people getting together
and just fighting each other as a way i
guess of
you know getting closer to something
real uh that popularized
fight clubs across america is that true
oh yeah brigham young university had as
many as 7 000 mormons beating on each
other
yeah they won't
they won't drink coffee but
let some coffee i can't have it now
let's trip to the waste and beat the
crap out of each other
and the governor's son got arrested for
running a fight club in a temple of
mormon a mormon temple right in provo
utah right so that's a great compliment
too right
so you've caused vomiting
you've almost killed molly sims here
and now you've got mormons beating each
other in the temple it's great uh the
book diary uh is uh is in bookstores now
and uh i hope you'll come back sometime
because there's a lot more to talk about
and uh is that possible you think you'd
ever come back um yeah next year ask me
back i'd love to please
i think we got our own fight club right
now pal
oh wait that hurt even standing up
chuck paul and nick everybody will take
a break we'll be right back